everybody has to deal with hardship
everybody has to do with struggle and
there's this great quotation from
hemming Hemingway the world is a hard
place he said in the world breaks
everyone he said and many are strong at
the broken places now people often
remember this phrase strong at the
broken places but it's also important to
remember his qualifier many not all are
strong at the broken places and some
people when they confront hardship
actually end up in a place where they're
helpless some people are broken by
suffering some people are actually
really hurt by pain in such way that
they can't move forward but it's also
the case that some people deal with
hardship and become heroic and one of
the things that I've tried to do in
these letters to my friend is actually
shown what you have to do in a really
practical way to actually build
resilience and be heroic now one of
those things is that you have to learn
how to take responsibility if there was
a single question that you can ask
someone to measure how resilient they're
going to be you ask them what are you
responsible for and what you find is
that even in the most difficult
situations when you look at stories of
people who have been prisoners of war
for example people who survived said I'm
going to take control of my thoughts or
I'm going to take control of the way
that I breathe there are certain things
even though my freedom has been taken
away from either my ability to eat where
I live all of these things have been
taken away from me I'm still going to
control something and when you focus on
on actually taking control of something
and what happens is your circle of
control begins to widen and people begin
to see that even in the face of hardship
and difficulty there's a way for them to
build power and live a purposeful life
so this book came when I was driving
down highway 70 in the middle of
Missouri and my buddy Zach Walker called
me now zach is a tough kid from a
northern California logging family he
was in my buds class my basic underwater
demolition Co training class and even in
a CEO training class he was one of the
toughest of the tough guys in this in
this class and we stayed friends after
we left the training he went to the East
Coast I stayed on the west coast and he
came back from a deployment in
Afghanistan and when he came back things
were going alright at first he was a
good father to his two young
kids he bought a concrete pumper he
started a small business and then his
life was just hammered by hardship what
happened was his brother died he lost
his business and one day he drove his
truck into his driveway he got out of
the truck and fell to the ground because
he believed that there was a sniper
watching him and he laid there for hours
until the Sun went down and then he got
up and he ran into the into his house
and he realized he had post-traumatic
stress disorder and then he started
drinking and on the weekend it was not a
six-pack but a cooler full of beer that
he was working on and he called me after
he'd been arrested so you had this guy
who was a Navy SEAL war hero coming home
from Afghanistan who now is the
unemployed alcoholic on disability who's
looking at having his kids come to visit
him in jail and we talked a lot that
night when I got home I started writing
him a letter he wrote back to me and we
did this for months with letters back
and forth in the book now is a series of
edited letters to my friend Zach Walker
about how you can take a lot of this
wisdom that's in our philosophical and
religious traditions how you can take a
lot of wisdom from your own experience
and use it to build a resilient life